me gustaría mencionar una una cuestión
ese aumento del 6,6% Fue de más del 7%
en las zonas del noreste y el Noroeste
argentino que son las más pobres del
país y es muy importante destacar que de
todos los rubros que aumentaron el
aumento mayor de 9,8% a nivel nacional
fue en alimentos y bebidas durante
muchos meses el año pasado el aumento
había sido por ejemplo en textiles en
ropas en calzado que son elementos
productos de los que uno puede esperar
para hacer la compra pero en alimentos
es clave y afecta especialmente a los
sectores más pobres Así que este
incremento es clave además fue
arrastrado sobre todo por la carne la
carne vacuna que venía con un acuerdo de
precios a fin del año 2022 ese acuerdo
Se terminó y tras el acuerdo de precios
efectivamente Bueno un empujón en el
precio en el precio de la carne así que
muy dura la situación para los
argentinos especialmente como te decía
los sectores más pobres del país
durísima situación de hecho natalianos
hable de Cómo afecta esto la vida diaria
de los argentinos hace bastante tiempo
ya que enfrentan precios cada vez más
altos Cuál es hoy el escenario
especialmente natalio porque estamos en
un año electoral no de elecciones
presidenciales de hecho
Mira fundamentalmente genera muchísima
desorientación es muy difícil planificar
y saber Con cuánto se va a contar y
cuánto de ese dinero con el que se va a
contar a fin de mes va a alcanzar qué se
va a poder comprar con eso esa es la
mayor dificultad y recordemos que
alrededor del 45% de los trabajadores en
Argentina están en el sector informal en
el sector formal ha habido aumentos de
precios acuerdos de aumentos salariales
a lo largo del año pasado y este año por
supuesto por detrás de la inflación en
la mayoría de los casos pero este 45%
del sector informal viene con muchísimas
más dificultades para ir siguiendo el
paso a la inflación eso posiblemente
termine generando un impacto también en
los niveles de pobreza cuando se
conozcan las nuevas estadísticas Todavía
están las de el segundo semestre de 2022
y pone por supuesto un tema central para
las elecciones presidenciales que va a
ser la inflación como bien decías en
Argentina y la pobreza algo que no se
resuelve fácil para las elecciones 2018
Perdón para las elecciones de 2015
Mauricio macri había dicho que iba a ser
muy fácil resolver ese problema no lo
fue el mismo día en que se conocieron
las cifras del indec uno de los
candidatos de la oposición Horacio
Rodríguez larreta dijo que le iba a
resolver el tema de la inflación y tal
vez pueda ser una condena porque
realmente no es sencillo resolver este
problema aquí en Argentina